at night and that's second cuz you know
it's going to be very vulnerable at
night at night we out cuz the Ducks they
come find
[Laughter]
you all right this one's more of a uh
Story Time article I'm going to tell you
I love these o I like it this is in uh
Colorado that this took place it's a
pretty messed up story but uh three
18-year-old psycho teen friends who have
nothing to do have this hobby of just
Gathering these big landscaping rocks
from in front of like uh oh dude
construction sites yeah and they load
them up into this pickup truck and they
this is something that they were doing
for months all right they regularly go
out to the highway and they just Chuck
them at cars oh my God so like they're
like on the top of a mountain and they
just drop the Rock and then the Rock
Falls so it doesn't explicitly say how
they're doing it they only drop them
into convert
here here's a crazy I don't think
they're dropping the Rocks I think what
they're doing they don't actually say I
tried to find exactly the method I think
what they're doing is they're driving
the opposite way on the highway and the
guys are in the back of the truck and
they throw it like oh no I think really
what I put together so they're not on
our Bridge no it doesn't say cuz in if
it's too heavy if it if that's what they
did the story be different but like so
uh here's what happened they were doing
this it sounds like like a Dustin or a
Tyler doing this [__] it's close yeah
yeah dude so they're doing for sure
Tyler over the course of two months uh
at least a dozen times oh my God [__]
Bradley man yeah [__] Bradley godamn
Bradley and Chadley dude that would be
sick dud if something like it how many
people did they kill they injured
several people including hitting a car
that would that had like a couple with
their small children they they just yeah
dude yeah yeah it was happening a lot
but then um eventually they can't find
these guys also also like if you're
doing this what do you think is going to
happen yeah they're like we're going to
rock their
work do rock puns the whole time they're
like a [__] these guys he's he's a cool
guy [__] but what do they think it's
just going to they're just going to dent
a car a little bit they didn't think
about like in their mind you think it's
a prank or do you think it's like I want
to [__] kill people like what do you
think it is basically what happened is
that he goes I want to rock and roll all
night they and party every day they're
basically like what happened is they
were saying that this kid there's like
one guy who's kind of the lead dude yeah
he's smooth brain's just a [__]
nutcase and that he's just he just
always wants to create chaos like he's
just that guy [__] Lord of CH uh
Colorado right here so what happens dude
he's like dude we're going to throw some
rocks D I don't think we should do that
shut the [__] up I didn't ask you what
you're thinking I'm telling you what
you're doing well actually that is part
of the case the truck you're like okay
it is part of where there was a fourth
kid who like didn't want to do it and he
was kind of integral to like how they
sort of not got caught but like told how
they got more of the uh story out [__]
dude these guys did get caught but then
this is this is what happened and how it
hit the absolute worst um outcome so
they uh eventually they were they threw
a big rock that went through the
windshield of a 20-year-old girl's car
yeah and the blow to her head killed her
car swerved into the field and then the
guys circled back to um to just check
out the damage and like take photos of
her and stuff [__] just to be like so
they're not even remorseful so they did
it as like a momento like to like have
this thing and then and then um now they
have evidence on their phone and then
once that happened and they discovered
that she had died they were like oh now
we we need to rename ourselves the blood
brothers because we finally got a kill
how lame how old are they a uh 18 how
[__] lame The Blood
Brothers these guys why does some why
does crazy [__] always come from
Colorado remember like the [__] the
the school shooting yeah that's
interesting that you bring it up so like
uh the movie theater one too right was
that Colorado no no no that wasn't
Colorado that's aora it Aurora yeah was
Colorado but this is on I think Arvada I
don't know but that that is like school
shooter DNA though like same typ of
[__] which is which is why like
that's cool that you're bringing that up
because um basically in Colorado they
have this in other states but Colorado I
think has a more specific statute on it
it's called Uh Cycles are welcome or
something it's called Extreme
indifference it's an actual like charge
so like uh oh [__] they were charged all
three of them with first-degree murder
among a long list of [__] but in those
charges it said extreme indifference
like they don't give a [__] human it's
what they yeah it's basically don't give
a [__] it's clearly defined as like it
shows that you are not you don't have uh
remorse yeah you don't have remorse but
you also have a sense of universal
malice where you just want bad things to
happen that's kind of sociopathic right
ex is that what they say like you don't
have no remorse you can't really feel
for other people they should call it
Joker symptoms yeah I think they'll call
It joker symptoms yeah yeah it's crazy
not having feel he's like this is that
could it be honestly like not to get too
deep yeah all right get deep you know I
like to get deep go deep go deep
bro but let's get smart be because do
you think like not hugging your kids or
telling your kids you love them could be
a you think you think I'm not connecting
with some I think it's prescription
pills oh yeah I heard that Colorado got
a crazy problem with they have an opioid
problem yeah yeah opioid America has a
pill problem I think it's the hugging
too much hugging too much support no no
no no I'm just be real like like are
they white kids reason why I'm not in
the gang is cuz my mom loved me like I
really that's one of the reasons I don't
like I don't know I wonder what their
parents are like my friends used to be
like yo we're going to do I'm like yeah
but why here's the this is the girl girl
that passed
away these are the guys that did it a
bunch of Mis cre dude this whoa he looks
like your guys' territory oh [__] he's
your territory dude I thought that was a
woman no dude that's these [__]
are scary he could be half your
territory too we don't know oh [__] he
[__] dude that guy he might be a Rees
or something be a miso cuz you're right
cuz of the night soccer look a little
bit your territory turns out he was all
ours whoa his name is Joseph coig though
I don't think that's Asian coig well
that's Asian mixed with a white man yeah
probably what if what if he's neither
what if he's Native American that's what
I thinking but don't do this to me yeah
so what this is the way closer tox after
they um so the girl by the way that girl
looked old enough for a kiss I'm sorry
like I had to I'm sorry I had to hey
don't do that to me dude D I'm [__]
kiss your lips right
now I had to dude that's what he's
talking about 12 but 13 in September old
enough for kisses old enough for a
kissar I always wonder what happens when
the families of these people see these
videos I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
something tells me she they're not going
to see this yeah so uh what I mean it
happens sometimes really and they don't
know anything about us and how stupid we
are really yeah and then they go why the
[__] would you do this it's like I'm
sorry we're a [__] News Channel we would
do that about our own tragedies anyways
and we're trying to educate these people
that do this [__] hello careful boys
hello yeah just be careful but also guys
have you guys ever been like uh put in
this situation not the situation we're
not done but in a situation where you
got tricked by your friends a group of
friends to influence you to do some dumb
[__] like dangerous dumb [__] I was
usually the influencer or were you guys
old enough to be like yeah we're not
doing this I usually liked it though
yeah you know when you had that feeling
of like adrenaline and like the hair on
the back of your neck stands up I like
that let's get into some [__] so if I if
my friends told me to go do something
like that at that age I'd be like [__]
yeah but how many hugs were you getting
from your mom's during that time that
that makes sense that makes sense my mom
never really hug me my mom didn't really
hug me but I was always like afraid of
everything so I'd be like I'm not going
to get in trouble I'm not going to do
this you but you would watch you would
watch I'd watch be like I'm going home I
would just leave but do you think you
would have the
do this like let's say that you're 18
your friends are like let's throw rocks
off the freeway or whatever we all throw
rocks let's say that you did it right oh
100% if somebody died would you have the
same reaction that these guys did [__]
no [__] yeah exactly that's like yeah i'
be like holy [__] I didn't mean that's
yeah that's a slaping your the
difference is that we all want to do
stupid [__] we want I think it's normal
to want to do destructive [__] as a
18-year-old but this outcome I don't
think anybody like I didn't want that to
happen I would want to do the stupid
[__] but I wouldn't want
some when I was a kid we went to the
there was like a little Lake and they
had a bunch of ducks and we were like
skipping rocks and we're like What if we
hit one of those ducks and everybody was
aiming for a duck trying to skip and hit
a duck and we were all aiming for it no
one can hit it they were [__] far
dude I don't know why but I just had
that that [__] that perfect [__]
skip went and they just [__] and the
and the duck just and I'm like and I'm
just stuff went was flapping and I
[__] my heart's RAC everybody's like
but you got it dude [__] but I'm more
like what the [__] what did I do and I
the seeing the dead duck [__] me up
and I was like oh dude this sucks and
everybody was just like this guy's a
[__]
Savage and I'm like yeah you're and then
when I went home it was like the guilt
was in me still and I had to tell my mom
and I told my mom my mom was making me
feel a little bit better like it was an
accident now you know was on accident
how it feels and you won't do it again
it was almost
premeditated it was mostly premeditated
with the [__] sniper shot I meant to
hit him earlier he's like it was my 13th
shot yeah I know it was an accident even
though I threw at it like 20 times but
and I tried to kept the secret from my
dad cuz I know he would have made it
worse which he did he heard like hey
what happened no nothing nothing what
happened no it's cuz he killed a
dock he k a they kill the dck and then
you
k at night and that's second cuz you
know it's going to be very vulnerable at
night at night we out cuz the Ducks they
come find
you that's perfect and they going to
grab your legs and they going to pull
you I'm just like they got
hands my D is like no but no I don't
want to pull my legs pull your legs out
on because you kill something
that's a good parent I swear to god dude
and we're at church and [__] we got
to ask for forgiveness I killed a duck
hey the duck killer over
here why is he got to burn you like dude
he burns me dude he's like but that's a
good dad yeah it's true it's true it's a
good
dad we're over there to get that little
bread thing in her tongue and then
before I I go over there my dad behind
me Whispers to the priest like he killed
someone might need he might need two to
to just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
his smart people the people of just
kidding news careful boys they are very
smart just kidding news the number one
foodcast in the
[Music]
world